kaylynn Malarkey's we are here in
beautiful Malibu celebrating the
beautiful launch of your one more time
beautiful collection with boo hoo how
does it feel for you to be a part of
this partnership it feels big it's
amazing so I have been a fan of boo hoo
since I was in college and so to see
this today and come into fruition and
see all my friends wearing the clothes
that I hand selected has been incredible
that's kind of crazy to say out loud
your best friends are here wearing
clothes that you selected yeah does that
feel a little bit like a dream it
absolutely feels like a dream I've been
into fashion for years now so to watch
this come to life has been incredible so
as your hand selecting these pieces and
putting this edit together what did you
want the vibe of it to be what's the
feel of it I wanted my vibe of this edit
to be exactly what I'm gonna be wearing
this fall exactly what I've been
attracted to you for this season for
this fall and everything that I'm gonna
be wearing so I wanted exactly that but
I also wanted pieces that are easy to
style in your own in your own way and I
feel like that's that's very accessible
in this edit what I love about what
you're wearing right now is I sometimes
I'm so on the go that I don't want to
put a full outfit together so we've gone
for a jump suit moment it's all one
thing
this is grace I love it we are
streamlined yes and how much is living
in a van affected the fashion choices
you have to make yeah living in a van
has affected my fashion choices
tremendously more so the makeup
somewhere so I've lost makeup and lost
like the pageantry side of myself and
embrace the natural side and wearing
less makeup so I still get to kind of
like pick my outfits yet carefully and I
pack a lot less I pack in just a
carry-on out but yeah it's been it's
been an adjustment
Wow just to carry on I mean that's the
way to go because you never know where
you're gonna go next in the van right
are you and Dean like that are you just
making decision by decision we're gonna
go wherever try whatever yeah I was just
talking my girlfriends and I was like I
don't know what's next and I don't know
how long I'm gone for but let's plan for
this cuz I know I'll be here at this
time but you just booked us a trip and I
don't know where we're going
somewhere internationally I have an idea
of where we're going but where do you
want to go I want to go to the Maldives
I think we're going somewhere cold
though cops it yeah so tell them what it
is that's working so well about you and
Dean together because you guys really
seem like you've grown and like gotten
really close in the past couple months
in and it seems very solid yeah these
past it we've been dating for almost
four months now and it's been incredible
I've learned so much about myself and he
challenges me he makes me a better
person and in most relationships I've
dealt with kind of a sort of complacency
and relationships people are just
complacent in their lives and they're
happy where they're at which is not not
an issue but Dean is always searching
for more and he's making me want to
better myself and search for more as
well so it's been great kaylynn luck
I'll be honest if you have known Dean
for a minute now and he's been on a
journey and I love hearing you say that
he's not complacent that he's
prioritizing you it's almost a little
bit like wow we've witnessed the growth
of Dean what kind of way friend is he
would be people be surprised to know Ono
Dean's this like really good boyfriend
I mean Finas Dean he'll never change but
he is the best boyfriend and I was just
raving about him because he has the
biggest heart out of everyone I've ever
met he loves everyone he meets and just
makes everyone feel so special and so
loved and he makes me feel oh it and
what more can you ask for so are you
guys in love yeah maybe we've said that
word maybe we haven't you know it takes
time okay well you know it's something
for some people but I like that you're
taking the time yeah good tell me about
the likelihood of Dean launching a
capsule collection of his own like how
into fashion is Dean he works a beanie
few works of beanie here except bucket
hat but Dean has about five shirts four
pairs of shorts and that's the extent of
his uh his wardrobe that Sam is working
so you were talking a little bit about
kind of like abandoning your pageant
past it's interesting is that something
Hannah's talked about too when you guys
say that is it sort of you like growing
into who you are now is it
finding new confidence can you expand on
what that means a little bit
yeah so in pageantry I learned so much
about myself and I grew so much and I
kind of broke out of my shy comfort zone
that I was living in but I don't know
going on a Bachelor and coming to these
realizations of yourself I have grown to
know this new side of me and this side
that's not like picture-perfect and like
say the right thing do the right thing
and just like act a certain way it's
like I'm a human and it's okay to like
be flawed and make mistakes and it's
kind of shutting that layer of
perfection yeah will there be any more
reality TV of any kind in your future I
think no I'm very happy my relationship
with Dean and I hope that you know this
is my last relationship and the
franchise and any reality TV okay would
you do anything else like is it know to
love based shows or knows whole of
things okay I don't know what I'm that's
all I can like think of right now but
yeah I mean you are wearing the DC
necklace we got it yeah like it's right
there meeting Kayla Dean and Kailyn
District Columbia will you and Cass
Cassie was here at the event today you
guys are still living in the same
building when are we gonna see a double
date with you and Dean and Colton Cassie
like I know there's an X Factor there
but still we've all moved past it right
yeah yeah no they're they've got to be
good I was just talking to her about
that we have to have it soon we've both
been traveling on different schedules so
I think we're here for a little bit so
that double date will be coming soon do
you have any predictions we just saw
Ashley and Jared get married to Rachel
and Brian any predictions on who in this
whole world might get married next
hopefully Dylan and Hannah are next and
then Kristen and Demi right after that
oh you've got a list
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]